South Korean President Pakti believed
that steel is national power. He wanted
a huge integrated steel mill in South
Korea. But the Western powers were
skeptical. South Korea was extremely
poor without substantial iron reserves,
their workers uneducated. For South
Korea to go straight to what was then
the most capital inensive heavy industry
was to defy economic orthodoxy. Too
soon, too inefficient.
But Pakuni believed Korea needed steel.
So he pushed his country to build what
would turn out to be one of the world's
most advanced steel companies.
In today's video, we go back to the
world of steel and recount one of South
Korea's most iconic companies, POSCO.
When Paktanghi took power in 1961, South
Korea was in a perilous state. The
country was still recovering from the
devastation of the Korean War. Its
security heavily depended on aid from
its ally, the United States. But this
relationship was testy even in the best
of times. And the post-war South Korean
economy was poor, struggling from trade
deficits, low foreign exchange reserves,
rampid inflation, and stalling growth.
The per capita income was about $80 and
the country can barely keep itself from
starving.
To solve this, Pac imagined a massive
industrialization effort to make the
South Korean economy self- sustaining.
This effort needed steel, modern steel
made right in South Korea.
However, many of the steel mills built
during Korea's colonial era were located
in North Korea. Prior to the Korean War,
President Singman Ree tried to build the
South Korean steel industry but failed
due to a lack of capital and government
coordination.
And then there was the Korean War
itself, which devastated the country's
industrial areas. The Bank of Korea
calculated that 75% of the country's
pre-war capacity in steel and iron was
destroyed.
sought to rebuild all that capacity
and more. He was convinced that South
Korea cannot forge its own other key
industries, automotive, ship building,
heavy industry without first making
steel. Thus, he made iron and steel
making the focus of his administration's
first and second 5-year development
plans.
To build a massive integrated steel
mill, the South Koreans needed expertise
and lots of cash.
Pak Chongghi armed twisted for CHBO to
form Korea integrated steel mill Inc.
and sought partners. They first
approached West Germany. An agreement
was signed for a feasibility study in
March 1962
but fell through due to a lack of
financial resources. Korea Integrated
tried again in late 1962,
agreeing with an American investor
consortium for a steel mill in Ulan with
capacity of about 250,000 to 300,000
tons per year. The issue again, however,
was getting the money. Pac's
administration took control of the
central bank and financial sector to
funnel domestic savings towards his
projects. But the South Korean people
were very poor back then. there was not
enough domestic savings. So if he wanted
to get enough money to build an
integrated steel plant, it had to come
from abroad.
The South Korean government first turned
to the Americans for economic aid. But
this turned out to be tricky. Both the
US agency for international development
and the US import export bank declined.
The US government was urging PAC towards
democratization and civilian rule.
Issuing foreign aid felt like sending
the wrong message.
US aid also remarked that the South
Korean government should be focusing on
other sectors like energy,
transportation, machinery, and
communication rather than steel. But
single-mindedly pursued steel.
After the Korean integrated steel
failure, he deployed personal diplomacy
for his next effort.
During a US trip in 1965 to meet
American President Lyndon Johnson, he
also traveled to Pittsburgh to visit
Jones and Laughlin Steel Corporation's
Alquipa plant. Reporters reported him
watching the steel works and saying,
quote, "This is the most impressive, all
this fine modern equipment." End quote.
During this trip, Pac met with Fred Foy,
the chairman of Coppers, to discuss
cooperation.
Coppers was then one of the world's
leading steel mill engineering firms.
Foy was receptive to building a plant in
South Korea, as was the World Bank at
the time. Thus formed, in December 1966,
a consortium of players from the US and
Europe called Korea International Steel
Associates or Kissa. Their goal was to
raise money for and build a modern steel
mill in South Korea.
Kissa's job was to build a steel mill.
And Pac was not screwing around. He
announced the steel mill during his
presidential campaign in 1967.
When progress stalled for a few months,
Pac replaced his deputy prime minister
and the head of his economic planning
board. The new board then negotiated a
contract with Kisa, coming to a
tentative agreement in April 1967, where
Kissa would raise 130 million from both
foreign and domestic sources to fund a
600,000 ton capacity integrated steel
mill. Meanwhile, Pakanghi began looking
at potential Korean partners to lead the
steel mill build. By the summer of 1967,
one company emerged as the leader to do
it. Korea tungsten mining led by one of
South Korea's rising stars TJ Pac
Pac Jun I shall refer to him as TJ
because Pacqu Pac was born in 1927.
As a child he went to Japan with his
father for work. He then studied
business at Waseda University before
returning to Korea upon the end of World
War II. He then joined the military
where he fought with honor in the Korean
War. TJ first met Pacch Chong Hei at the
military academy when the former was a
cadet and the latter a company
commander.
The elder Pac took a liking to the cadet
and respected his intelligence and also
trusted him. TJ did not participate in
the 1961 military coup, supposedly
because if the coup were to fail, then
TJ was to look after Pacchangh's family.
After the coup succeeded, TJ served as
Pakunhi's chief secretary for 3 years.
He then declined to return to the
military and in 1964 was sent by his
government to Japan to build up business
contacts within industry.
He returned to South Korea a few years
later and was put in charge of a
state-owned enterprise called the Korea
Tungsten Mining Company. The company
controlled Sang Dong Mine, one of the
world's largest tungsten mines, and was
one of the few sources of foreign
currency for the country, but had fallen
into hard times. With effort, he brought
them back into the black.
Pakti ordered TJ to start preparations
for the construction of Kissa's
integrated steel mill. First things
first, where to put it. They spent a
year evaluating five different sites,
including Olsan. In the end, they chose
a sleepy fishing town with about 50,000
residents. Poan
was the original frontr runner, but
their own growing industry meant they no
longer had available space. Pohang still
had lots of open land and fresh water,
as well as a deep water harbor to
receive iron ore and coing coal. It was
also far enough from North Korea to not
be immediately threatened by artillery
and far enough from Seoul to diversify
away from the mega city. Local officials
emphasized the mill's impact potentially
on the then impoverished Korean East
Coast. Thus, in April 1968, the Poang
Iron and Steel Company was founded as a
private entity with 300 million Juan
from the government and 100 million from
Korea tungsten. Almost immediately, they
called it Pasco.
But meanwhile, Kissa was in trouble. A
seven member cross-cultural consortium
was always going to be unwieldy. But
when the Americans began to waver on the
issue, the West Germans and British did
too. Neither government opted to loan
money towards the project. At the heart
of the issue were divergent views
between the World Bank and the South
Korean government about the plant's
size. The Koreans wanted a very large
steelm plant capable of someday
producing 1 to2 million tons of steel
per year. The World Bank felt that was
too much. They did a feasibility study
in 1966 that asserted that the largest
steel mill that the South Koreans can
economically support was just 500,000
tons. 2 million tons of capacity
threatened to tip over the global steel
market.
Finally, in November 1968, the World
Bank officially declined a loan for
Kissa Steel Mill. They recommended that
the country pursue light industry
instead. A steel mill was premature and
not economically feasible. Kissa
dissolved a few months later. By then,
the South Korean economy was starting to
gather steam. Thanks to several major
construction projects, iron and steel
consumption was growing rapidly and well
ahead of projections, 15% year-over-year
in 1967.
Without an integrated steel mill that
can turn iron ore into pig iron and then
pig iron into finished steel, South
Korea relied on small privatelyowned
electric arc furnaces that melted down
scrap steel. And at about 10,000 tons
each, these mills lacked scale.
Whatever shortfall had to be fulfilled
with imports. In 1965, South Korea was
only 61.3%
self-sufficient in steel. Two years
later in 1967, that ratio had worsened
to 58.4%.
With the West proving unreliable, Pakuni
turned eastward. The United States
government had long wanted their allies,
Japan and South Korea, to make peace and
normalize relations. It would help
strengthen each other and shore up
anti-communist forces in Asia.
The growing Japanese economy also sought
access to new markets and the United
States was not open to granting further
access. The American diplomats
positioned normalization as a way for
Japan to develop a geographically close
market. This was never quite possible
while Singman Ree, a former Korean
independence activist, was in charge.
The historical wounds left behind by the
Japanese occupation were too fresh.
anti-Japanese sentiment very strong. Pak
Chongghi was a different man being
educated in Japanese institutions and
trained in their military. More
importantly, he was pragmatic and ready
to move on if that meant economic
opportunities for his country. Soon
after taking power, Pakchangi entered
normalization talks with Japan. And in
1965, they signed a treaty. As a part of
the reparations, the Japanese prepared
some $500 million in grants and
long-term loans to settle property and
claims issues.
When Kissa began to fall apart in 1969,
Puck thought to use some of the Japanese
reparation funds to build his long
desired integrated steel mill. This was
not as easy as it might seem. The
agreements were already signed. The
Japanese government initially declined
to join Kisa, generally agreeing with
the Westerners about the project's
infeasibility.
To secure their agreement, Pakanghi
pursued a two-track approach. First,
direct government-to-government
negotiations, which emphasized the value
of a stronger South Korea as a
deterrence against communist aggression.
Second, TJ leveraged his own personal
ties to Japanese industry. Japan's three
largest steel makers quickly got on
board. The main issue was the Japanese
government. Most of all, its powerful
Ministry of International Trade and
Industry, Midi. TJ met with Midi's
Minister Masayoshi O'Hira, a future
prime minister, and pressed the
strategic importance of steel, evoking
the history of Japan's own steel
industry,
including how Japan decided to build the
massive Yuata steel works in the late
1800s without concern to economic
viability. It was simply a question of
strategic necessity.
In August 1969, Korea's deputy prime
minister announced that the Japanese
changed their minds and were ready to
back the steel project. Yes, it was in
part due to Pacche's determination and
TJ's fervent lobbying, but it was also
just smart business. Kissa's collapse in
early 1969 gave Japan the opportunity to
lead the project without American or
European interference.
And the home Japanese steel market was
already overs supplied with social
repercussions regarding steel pollution
issues. Exports to Korea can maintain
sales of steel making equipment without
further exacerbating the domestic
situation.
This in part explains why the Japanese
steel companies were so in favor. The
Koreans played on this with one official
quoted as saying, quote, "If you help us
build a steel mill, your exports are
guaranteed and you can sell machinery."
End quote.
And lastly, the Japanese government saw
Pak Chunghi's determination to build his
integrated steel mill, plus the
country's skyrocketing steel demand, and
realized that if they passed, then
someone else, maybe the Germans, would
eventually step up.
In November 1969, the two began
negotiating on the cooperation details.
South Korea had earlier submitted a
project proposal for a 1 million ton
capacity integrated steel mill along
with cost estimates and requests for
technology. Japan opened negotiations
with a 64page counter proposal. They
budgeted the mill to cost 25% more and
require a year longer than what was in
the Korean estimate. They also declined
Korea's requests to transfer an advanced
steel milling technology called
continuous casting. This gamechanging
technology lets a mill cast molten steel
directly into finished shapes like
sheets, wires, and rods. Otherwise, the
molten steel must first be cast into
intermediate shapes like ingots or
billets before reheating to produce the
final shape, an energyintensive process.
The Japanese offered Pasco this older
technology.
From November 19th to the 21st, 1969,
the two sides clashed. South Korea
demanding the continuous casting
technology as well as an accelerated
construction schedule. The Japanese, on
the other hand, sticking to their
conservative assessments. The arguments
went late into the night. Finally, on
the 21st, the two sides reached a
compromise. The South Koreans agreed to
Japan's delayed timeline, a middle
number budget of 123 million between
Korea's 100 million and Japan's 131
million estimates, and the older
slabbing technology for the main steel
line. However, Japan did concede to
include a smaller continuous casting
unit.
The deal was signed in December 1969
between the South Koreans and Japan's
big three steel makers. Construction
would begin in April 1970 with
anticipated completion in July 1973.
As work began, TJ made clear the
enormity of their task. In June 1968, as
preparatory work began on track and
water infrastructure in Pohang, he gave
a speech to his construction staff. A
commonly cited quote cleaned up but
probably real has him saying, "This
steel mill is being built with the Korea
Japan claims settlement funds, the price
paid in the blood of our ancestors. If
we fail, it will be an unforgivable sin
in history. In that case, we should all
march out of the construction site
office, turn right, and throw ourselves
into Yongil Bay.
POSCO could not have existed without
nation state resources. Like as in
Japan, the South Korean central
government built out Pasco's
infrastructure. The Bohang local
government evicted residents lands for
the site and a special law was enacted
so that energy and water can be provided
to Pasco at discounted prices. Despite
that, TJ tried to run Pasco with as much
autonomy as possible and being the
president's friend, he got that. But
Pacchangh nevertheless remained deeply
involved, visiting the phase 1 site 13
times during the build between 1970 and
1973.
Pos substantially leaned on the Japanese
for phase 1. The Korean engineers were
asked to supervise and learn, but TJ did
make efforts to find separate sources of
coke and iron for Posco separate from
the Japanese trading companies.
TJ also exercised some financial cunning
by having the steel mill built
backwards. Usually steel mills are built
forwards. So from iron making to casting
to rolling into finished product. But
that means the mill doesn't generate
revenue until the whole thing is done.
And that could take 3 years. Posco was
in need of immediate income. So TJ asked
to build the phase 1 facility the
opposite way from rolling to iron making
so that POSCO can import semi-processed
steel slab and use that to make finished
products to sell. Workers pushed through
brutal sandy wind conditions. They
worked so hard that they were too tired
to go back to their quarters to sleep
and slept in the offices or on the
roadsides. When the initial foundation
fell behind schedule, TJ mobilized
massive resources to correctly but
quickly pour tens of thousands of tons
of concrete to catch up. Add in an
unexpected ship building boom that
caused demand for plate steel to
skyrocket, and the result was Pasco
turning profits in its second full year,
1970, far ahead of expectation.
The rest of the phase 1 build was
completed on time in July 1973. The
three years it took outclasses the usual
4 to9 years in other countries. By then,
Pak Chungghi's heavy and chemical
industries drive was in full effect. A
powerful thrust to build up the
country's military industrial capacity
to defend against North Korea. Steel
would be at the heart of this. So,
President Puck called to raise South
Korean steel capacity from 1 million
tons in 1973 to 10 million by 1980.
Bosow thus embarked on a massive
expansion that added almost 6 million
tons of steel over 5 years, phases 1 to
4. By then, the Koreans had been trained
and taken over for the Japanese.
Throughout this, TJ navigated delicate
geopolitics, domestic politics. was
assassinated in 1979 and a substantial
steel market glut in the mid 1970s.
After phase 3 was completed, TJ again
went to the aging president a few hours
before the latter's assassination
apparently and secured authorization to
build a second mill next to Pohhang
Guangyang steel. Begun in 1982, the
Guangyang steel mill adopted all the
latest technologies like the basic
oxygen furnace, continuous casting, and
computer control. And by laying these
units out in an innovative single line,
Guangyang's steel costs were 60% that of
the average American steel mill. Good
enough to start selling into the
Japanese markets and compete with the
Japanese steel giants. The student had
now become the master.
Today, Pasco is one of the world's most
efficient and advanced steel companies.
Measured by pure steel production in
2024, the company is eighth place, one
of the few non-mainland Chinese
producers to rank in the top 10, and
they rank very highly, probably maybe
even the top in terms of efficiency.
They also have a large geographical
footprint, particularly the mainland
Chinese market, which they entered in
the 1990s with great benefit. China to
this day remains one of their top export
destinations.
Few steel companies have an origin story
so deeply intertwined with their
country's rise from poverty. South Korea
went to the limit to get their chance to
build their integrated steel mill, and
the men and women of POSCO responded.
All right, everyone. That's it for
tonight. Thanks for watching. Subscribe
to the channel. Sign up for the Patreon.
And I'll see you guys next time.